what are five things a writer should
know about the TV writing room you take
two and a half and I'll take a head you
want me to start
yeah please know that to get in you 90%
chance you're gonna have to work your
way into the room as a as a script
assistant as a writers assistant those
jobs are plentiful and they're great and
you will get training and know that it
will take a while also know that when
you're a baby writer don't talk listen
nobody likes someone who answers
questions know that most people are good
at one or two things but nobody's good
at everything I think I answered three
that ladies don't be the smartest person
in the room
never ever first ever why because
everybody will hate you actually will
Joe runner and you won't be the smartest
person in the room and everybody will
see that and really you cannot be full
of yourself in the room I'm not gonna
mention the show and I'm not gonna
mention I will mention that it was my
friend Bob who who is very close as I
said to chuck lorre
who gave Chuck Lorre his break and Chuck
will call him every once in a while even
though bob is semi-retired he'll call
him up and say I really need help but it
was a point a couple years ago when he
had five shows on the air and he went on
one of the shows and he pitched a joke
and he said to Bob was that funny when
you were working on my two dads was that
funny back then facts of life he was
just and Chuck and and Bob went to Chuck
and he said I don't need the money I'm
out of here
and he left you know if you're a
showrunner the best kind of showrunner
you could be as somebody who mentors
other people who secure enough like Phil
Rosenthal to really care about getting
the best out of people that's the
message on a leader anyway we had a lot
of great stories about
rooms and showrunners and Peter Casey
was great he said I worked on The
Jeffersons and I came to to the room
late one day and I hadn't eaten
breakfast so I brought a little box of
cornflakes with me and I went to the
corner where the coffee was poured it in
and took a little of the cream put it on
there and the guy said that's not for
your cereal that's with a coffee and he
charged him like 25 cents for doing that
oh and he said they would now feed us
the worst food ever and he said when I
went to work on Cheers with the Charles
brothers they would take us out to
really good restaurants or if they had
to work really late they would call up
one of the really good restaurants and
we'd order from their menu and they
would deliver it
he said they treated the writers with so
much kindness and respect he said and
they got such great work at Hearst
nobody complained if it was late
we're with the Jeffersons like everybody
was grumbling all the time and hated
being in the room so he said the Charles
brothers made his Perla kittens house it
you actually said that but I'm taking
licensed ok was there one other I think
you only got one in that's four
altogether four so five total any five
be careful be careful okay know where
the exit I know what you're sort of this
is sort of repetitious but I think it
bears repeating it's really important
that when you get into a room you use it
as a learning experience because you're
one of very few people when I started
there was still a freelance market there
really is no freelance market anymore
and so if you have the luck to get into
a room take advantage of it and be
humble and Peter's right but I will add
a fifth just the sake of completeness
that every room has a culture oh that's
and you want to spend a lot of time
observing before you jump in and just
because one person makes a joke doesn't
mean everybody makes jokes and if one
person kids
another person that doesn't mean
everybody teases and you want to wait
and when you really understand how
people interact then you slowly test the
water and start to do it even then you
do it slowly
my two wonderful former students who
were on one day at a time we're on the
show now they're in their second season
they're not the baby writers anymore you
see how that works so they were on the
show they were on like three months they
were on like show seven or eight and
they hadn't said that much I mean
they've done their work they were the
first script their mentor wrote with
them so it was the three of them writing
it which was really generous of her that
doesn't know what's happened and she one
of them told me that they didn't say
anything one day and one of the one of
the writers said Caroline we'd really
like to hear what you guys think you
guys are these characters eight is one
of these characters age opening and yet
she said she began by the old what if
thing so that she left room to be wrong
if they didn't like what she said and
she said they were after that day they
were like you guys whenever you have
something to say say it don't be shy but
they were smart to wait because they
were learning they were observing and
they were only 25 years old that's young
to be in a room so and they didn't think
the show was gonna get a second season
and now it's big heads now
emmy-nominated is you know it's a big it
and by the way you tricked us you said
only three more questions and the first
one is a five partner don't think that
went past us it went past me you make
her laugh yes she has a low threshold
you